hi I'm Max Keiser this is the Kaiser
report and this is central bank monetary
policy yeah get it they see more money
they might call it it is so much money
mo our money more money and you know
what max now some people say all that
money printing is gonna cause inflation
and a devalues everybody else's currency
but they're offering us a bargain here
US Treasury expects to borrow two point
nine nine nine trillion a net marketable
debt in April to June quarter three
point zero five five trillion dollars
more than estimated in February two
point nine trillion dollars come on down
to the feds Park and basement two point
nine trillion dollars order now and get
six trillion dollars more in six months
order now get six trillion dollars more
in six months come on down to the Fed
bargain-basement hi I'm Jay Powell I
print money like a maniac come on down
to the feds bargain basement we'll give
you a trillion dollars right now you got
some old baseball cards you got some
come on right now you know this is
Christine Lagarde's yeah we know that
your French is not up to par but we're
going to hey I have a hundred euros
right on my jacket my velvet jacket I'm
feeling flush unprecedented the u.s.
expects to borrow a massive US dollar
three trillion or 14% of nominal GDP
during the second quarter alone current
outstanding
the debt is now 25 trillion dollars I
think we're about halfway there in this
room
Kaiser report never fails to deliver the
goods you know we've been saying now for
a few years that ultimately they're
going to 100 trillion dollars
Japan's already done a percent debt to
GDP on their Fed's balance sheet Kuroda
their central banker has already taken
their central bank above 100 percent of
GDP in terms of debt that's buying a lot
of junk a lot of assets so America at
six seven eight nine trillion dollars
they've got another 60 trillion to go
the globe is set to go to 100% GDP debt
to on the balance sheets of the central
banks so you know there's a hundred
trillion dollars to go that's stock
markets are booming in particular
sectors it's particularly in the banking
sector a member of the PPP program from
the feds it all went to JPMorgan first
they took their cut which was
substantial like 20% or more and then
whatever was left over they doled out to
the poor serfs and peasants in America
here
voila it's like you know papal
indulgences give us it will give you $10
if you give us $50 in banking fees says
Jamie Dimon I'm the Pope of bad money
I'm the Pope of Fiat Jamie Dimon my god
what a crook well you know they continue
to print apparently the u.s. deficit the
budget deficit will hit four trillion
dollars this year I remember the shock
only just recently in the last few years
here on Carson report of when the US
budget deficit hit one trillion and we
were like oh my god like this is the end
but apparently it's gonna go to four
trillion that's why they're borrowing
three trillion but they're saying all of
this infinite fiat is going to cause
infinity war because let's look at this
central bank's pandemic battle could
stretch into an infinity war big central
banks are buying from an expanding menu
of government bonds corporate debt and
consumer loans to help businesses and
households through the corona virus
pandemic and no one knows whether it can
stop right well again I was dead right
in
the central banks are taking the entire
economy private right they print the
money to buy all the income producing
assets buy all the stocks all the bonds
all the property all the leases all the
markets is everything right so they're
taking the entire economy private I've
mentioned that first as a concept maybe
three years ago here on Keiser Report
now you have news reports from
mainstream media saying oh my god what
if they never stop what do they just
keep buying everything with all their
printed money what would that mean so
there's two possible outcomes number one
is male feudalism where you have a
return to the Middle Ages
and all of the economies on by a few
oleg arks and everyone else are living
on you know peasant indentured servant
clique farms like click on the ads on
the social media to try to win a protein
pill the other outcome would be pure
somatization soviet ization of the
economy where the state owns everything
and everyone is equally poor that would
be the other outcome so but either one
of those two or where we're headed and
or a combination of the both so that
would be the worst of both possible
situations a pure caki stock recei but
one thing that's not coming back is a
free market American capitalism well
plucky's coming back because he loves
money printing remember last episode we
wrote him off we said the days of Fiat
are over this is their Hail Mary all
this money printing going on he is of
course British that's why he's so
spindly like this but he's got to print
some pounds here
that's for the Queen that's for the
queen the queen is financially she well
in the extreme case that are occurring
virus requires further damaging
lockdowns the US Federal Reserve and as
peers float the whole boat government
debt corporate debt perhaps even
financing for mortgages and paychecks of
course max we're gonna need a bigger
boat right that's the old saying out in
Jaws land where you know the black
whole of debt is well I should actually
put plus wait a minute you're saying
plucky's British because that machine
toy was loaded with pounds that's a
that's not right
plucky is is a red white and blue
American chicken no that would be a big
plump one we bought this in when we were
in the United Kingdom but you know what
so here they talk about the infinity war
because of course all fiat is measured
just against other fiat so if they're
all collapsing and they're all spreading
around in a big pile of junk on our you
know studio floor here well there's no
way to tell which one is more devalue
than the other they're all a devaluing
against each other but it's also caused
a great deal of you know strife in for
the American population not only how we
had to export all our jobs in order to
export dollars to maintain our reserve
currency status but the Fed constantly
has to intervene for the whole entire
world when these crises happen because
every time a crisis happens the dollar
goes up and therefore all the other
economies in the world suffer because
there's a shortage of dollars and time
out of worker Rhodes skills business
failures destroy wealth and depress
investment cheap money and cash
transfers risk fuelling asset bubbles
that widen the gap between rich and poor
as we've talked about the Cantillon
effect and the rise of the Cantillon air
class yeah that's right they can't
Chilean air class people to just shake
down the Fed like Warren Buffett but
even that has limitations I could said
really denied warren buffett you know he
was trying to shake down the airline
industry during the crisis over the past
couple of months and get sweetheart
deals in freebies and guaranteed profits
and the Fed stepped in and said no we're
gonna be buying airline shares in front
of Warren Buffett they front-run Warren
Buffett the ultimate frontrunner they
give you an idea cuz the Fed is now much
bigger than Berkshire Hathaway it's much
bigger than any of these private equity
groups and that's the purpose is to take
everything private for the people who
own the Federal Reserve Bank of America
which they were about 20 or 25 families
and that's it so importantly you know
with a can tell Ian Ayre class and with
Cantillon effect what happens as you
know base
Klee Basquiat would have warned you
about this corruption spreads right the
corrupt class consolidates as wealth and
and basically feeds each other the free
money and one thing I was told in
confidence oh I can't give the source
but in the past week somebody has told
me that they used to work basically with
somebody within the New York Fed and
anytime there was a crisis like this
like I eat the government was about to
tell Airlines that they couldn't fly at
all and they were gonna shut down all
airline flights normally what would
happen is how they get around the
insider trading is they're saying we're
calling you know where the New York Fed
and we're calling the experts we're
gonna call all the experts out there
like that
just because we want to help you the
ordinary people who are not continuing
errors so we're gonna call Warren
Buffett and say hey Warren we know you
own 10% of the big four airline stocks
in America what would you think if we
had to shut down all flights I there
signaling to him this is coming they're
not giving him inside information
they're saying they're just asking this
benevolent ukulele playing guy to give
some free advice to the ordinary people
right if you do our forensic analysis of
Buffett deals over the past 30 years
you'll find a similar quid pro quo in
virtually all of them it's all inside
information inside information is the
hardest crime to prosecute of all major
crimes and their way to get around it
are almost infinite and that what you
just described is one way to get around
insider trading law and Buffett though
is having trouble because he helped fuel
the rise of this monster the Fed and now
it's attacking him it's like the
Frankenstein you know the movie
Frankenstein is about the mad scientist
dr. Frankenstein the monster had no name
so dr. Frankenstein Warren Buffett
created the monster created the Fed this
nameless money-printing rogue
contraption that is putting everyone out
of business and nobody can stop it but
also in the last days of empire as we've
catalogued herein chronicled here on
Kai's report for the last 10 years
you do get hyper-partisanship and we're
having hyper-partisanship and Warren
Buffett is a well-known Democrat and he
sponsors Democrats he clearly doesn't
like Trump and therefore he's not
getting those calls Steve minuchin is
not calling Warren Buffett to say hey
what would happen if we shut down the
airline clearly Warren Buffett who said
the ultimate insider the Fiat infinite
Fiat Insider he had no idea this was
coming because remember before he dumped
all his shares he bought more Delta
shares 1 million on February 27th so he
clearly was not given any warning about
this ok that's that's something we need
to dig into a little bit because you're
saying in this case due to political
partisanship he was not tipped as he
always has been or usually is and this
would make sense then in retrospect
because he dumped those airline shares
like a petulant child yes he had just
bought Delta a million Delta a couple of
weeks before at an all-time high I might
add and then suddenly because he wasn't
tipped on the inside information he
became a brat and said well I don't care
I'm just gonna blow it all out and I
don't care who's hurt the hard-working
men and women of America to hell with
them he said on his conference call he
still believes in America while he
stabbed in the back America and now he's
losing horribly in his reputation is
trashed and finally max it gets to the
question at what point are we worried
with just how much a role the Fed is
playing said Catherine Judge of Columbia
Law School professor who studies
financial markets if they are the only
actor and people are worried about
liquidity and access to finance how much
pressure comes to bear longer-term it is
disconcerting right how much were they
in they're not gonna stop as we've been
saying that cos report for years they
will not stop until every last stock and
bond a piece of property in America and
other places around the world is bought
by this private consortium of bankers
called the Federal Reserve Bank and we
are then into neo feudal times mixed
with the little Soviet ization to give
it some nice flavor well I'm gonna take
a break and when we come back myself and
plucky and Stacy won't be here it'll
just be me and a guest don't go away
welcome back to the constant report on
Max Keiser time now to speak with
Laurence Lepard he is over there at the
equity management associates you can
follow him on Twitter I follow him on
Twitter he's got lots and lots of really
good stuff to find out all by his words
on hard money wisdom etcetera Laurence
welcome to the cars report oh thank you
max honored to be with you guys I've
followed max at Stacey for years as I
said week before you guys are the OGS of
sound money so it's with you oh cool Wow
alrighty let's get into it
so I Laurence you write in your latest
newsletter the Rubicon has been crossed
and the US government does goes direct
with helicopter money elaborate on this
what is helicopter money in this case
and what happens from here sure as I'm
sure a lot of your listeners know I mean
in 2008 they started increasing credit
and printing money and and we all
thought hyperinflation would follow and
we were wrong and some of us suffered as
a result of that what they did was they
really plugged the hole that had been
created by the collapse the debt
structure in the housing market and but
the money didn't make it to the people
the money made it into the stock and
bond markets and so we created a bubble
there and and velocity fell and and so
you didn't although inflation is
understated as we all know you didn't
really see the inflation that we
expected in that particular cycle and
the reason is the money didn't really
get to the people and in this particular
case that certainly has changed I found
it fascinating that you know pre the
kovat crash you know the notion of
printing money or giving money to people
or or being running large deficits was
with someone enough but to so many
people and you know Andrew yang and
Bernie Sanders were considered you know
nut jobs and of course the minute there
the minute the stock market that the 1%
owners threatened with a liquidity in a
crash and you see all the you know the
risk ARB guys going out of business they
certainly figure out a way to get money
to the people and so all of the checks
are a pittance you know the the direct
money sent to corporations
and all the all the money that they're
using and printing and distributing that
represents the helicopter money that
Friedman talked about so many years ago
and then that Bernanke irresponsibly
signaled was a possibility going forward
and and we're there and of course once
you start that you can never stop and
everybody listening this already knows
that and so it will only grow and as my
good friend Dan Oliver says this time
we're going to get inflation you know
good and hard it's coming so and even to
the degree we get short term deflation
and something like the price of oil it
doesn't really matter because I I would
submit and this is counter to Lacey
Hunt's argument that falling velocity is
going to create is gonna you know
protect the money I would submit that
what's going on really here's what I
call C sip which is currency
substitution inflation and people are
going to start to see that you know the
dollar is no good I mean if you look at
the if you look at the united states
government you look at their deficits
you look at the balance sheet you
realize that it's just completely
bankrupt this government is is beyond
bankrupt and so as a result of that it's
just a matter of time until people wake
up and they realize that having savings
that are dollar denominated or whether
they be in cash or bonds it's just gonna
be a very bad place to be and all it's
gonna take is a break out of the gold
price from something north of 1700 to
1900 which is the old high and then into
the two thousand three thousand range
and and then Gresham's law will take
over in my view and you know it'll be
will be on our road to what I sadly
think is a Weimar like outcome I hope
they're smart enough to maybe try
restructuring before that but looking at
the politicians that we have in office
today I I can't I can't with good
conscience say that's a high likelihood
event so sorry that's a long answer I'm
actually I wanted to come set the stage
right well done so we're gonna get into
this money velocity number and chart in
a moment but I just wanted to go back to
what you were saying there in terms of
the expectation in 2008 with all the
money printing would be inflation we
didn't have that inflation we actually
had more deflation and looking back now
it does make sense that we would have
more deflation because looking at the
big picture
laurens starting in 1971 when
the u.s. closed the gold window and we
went into a global fiat currency land
where all money is issued without
backing and so it can be said that all
fiat money is debt money it's all
brought into existence as debt and so if
in fact the debt money which does have
an interest rate attached to it is
floods the economy and then the need to
pay interest on that debt means do you
have to issue more debt money to pay off
the existing debt money well then you're
gonna have a situation of Perpetual
deflation because you're flooding the
economy with debt and debt results in
deflation when the debt can't be paid
when you have a debt default the u.s.
defaulted on its economy on its notes on
its obligations in 1971 and they
replaced gold with fiat money nonsense
and now that default 40 45 years later
and after going through the crisis of
2008 has metastasized into the crisis of
2020 which is 10 to 50 times bigger so
what I want to get into here is all the
terms being used inflation versus
deflation and these two terms are
defined differently by different camps
out in the economic study however one
chart and one graph and one data point
has been resolute in depicting what's
really going on and that would be the
money velocity chart which I think has
really given us a clearer picture of
what's happening can you tell us what
the money velocity chart is and what
it's telling us sure it's it's a
function how much money is moving
through the system and it's been going
down consistently and Lacey Hunt was
very early in picking this and
understanding what it implied and you
know I like James Turks view of it I
mean money velocity falling actually if
you look at hyperinflations in the past
what the velocity is falling because
it's just so damn much money out there
that you don't need that you know you
don't need a lot of velocity to keep the
economy where
is and and so what you've really done is
you shoved more fake money into the
system and you know that there are
deflationary forces going on you know
and we had other deflationary things
happening to I mean China and the China
price and internet and technology and so
forth um and and so as a result you know
it's been somewhat masked but as you
pointed out different people view
inflation and deflation in different
ways I mean I think in consumer prices
we're gonna have a mixture of both I
mean I know for example we have a lot of
inflation in the price of eggs in my
town there are three hundred percent but
we've got a lot of deflation in the
price of gasoline and so you know that's
to me not what's really relevant in this
picture here for all of us as investors
I think the the relevant area to look at
is is the asset area and that's where I
got to my si sip thought which is laid
out my q1 report which is that you know
where are you gonna put your savings I
mean assuming you really have savings
many people don't certainly the
government doesn't have any but to the
degree that you have savings you have
legitimate asset that's where do you
want them to be where they best treat it
on a going-forward basis and I would
submit strongly and I know the two of
you agree that you know the precious
metals in Bitcoin are really the two
obvious places you want to be for a
second Lawrence because I want to follow
up on what comment you made there that
the money velocity shows that too much
money is in the system so let's unpack
that for a second because we did
establish that we're talking about debt
and debt is not the same thing as money
money is only really gold or Bitcoin
when you have a fiat currency that's
debt based you have a flood of that into
the economy then we see the money
velocity go go down if this were actual
money if the money if the fiat if the
currency if the dollar were backed by
gold there would be a natural
competition to own the gold to own the
money and people would work to
accumulate more money more gold and they
would be interpret entrepreneurial and
banks would lend to businesses and that
money would end up in this
being lent out to new businesses and
money velocity would go up because
people are competing for gold back or
money backed by gold but because it's
only paper that's backed by nothing and
the way to get it is to petition the
bank to get a bailout and they print it
for nothing and it's worth nothing then
you get this money velocity collapsed
because there's no competition anymore
in America it's all about positioning
yourself in Washington and proximity to
the Fed to get the free paper nonsense
money and that's what the money velocity
shows now to your point about gold
bullion the gold bullion is making new
all-time highs every major currency in
the world by leaps and bounds by huge
huge amounts except the US dollar
because the US dollar is reserve world
reserve currency has particular
attributes that prevent it from hitting
new all-time highs today but you believe
it will be hitting new all-time highs
and u.s. dollar terms soon and could be
heading in between the six to twenty
thousand dollar per ounce level based on
what exactly Laurence can he dig into
that for us absolutely max I mean what's
going on here is there's a very tight
relationship between the federal budget
deficit and the growth in the gold price
and in my report which I'm sending out
for free you can see that Meridian macro
has done a very nice job of capturing
that and what you see is that the
federal deficit last year was about a
trillion dollars this year at a run rate
it's running at about six trillion
dollars so there's a five trillion
dollar increase and the price of gold
goes up $500 for every 500 billion or
$1,000 for every trillion of budget
deficit so basically what this math says
if this correlation holds is that the
price of gold is going to go up by
$5,000 as this deficit I'm full so that
would imply $6,700 gold price you know
basis today's price and you know I think
it's it's likely to happen and
historically looking at the charts if
you overlay debt over a gold price going
back 40 years they always go together
except for the last few years
where they've done an amazing job and
breaking that relationship but it looks
like that relationships coming back
which would imply 6000 plus per ounce of
gold yes absolutely and I think the
reason they were able to break the
relationship as they started another
credit cycle and they've been extremely
effective at using tools you know we all
know what they are to create paper gold
and suppress the gold price which they
know is the canary in the coal mine to
the system they're running cool now how
do people get in touch with their
newsletter Lawrence are you giving away
copies I hear ya copies of the
newsletter are free just because I want
more people on this side of the trade
it's my email address this L apart so ll
EPA rd @ EMA to Edward mark alpha to
comm send me an email
I'll put you on the list every quarter I
write something explaining how I'm
viewing the situation talks about gold
stocks etc yeah and Bitcoin too because
as we know Bitcoin is gold thanks for
being on the Kaiser report thank you
very much max thanks Stacey sure that's
gonna do it for this edition of the
Kaiser report with me max Kaiser and
Stacy
Herbert want to thank our guests
Lawrence Lepard you can find him on
Twitter you can find us on Twitter the
Kaiser report till next time bye Oh
[Music]